hier sitzt jemand der den Blick aufs
große Ganze hat wir haben dieser Tage
auch schon mal darüber gesprochen Herr
tu's
wir neigen dazu sozusagen von oben nach
unten top down einfach an zu sagen bis
in den Heizungskeller hinein bis der
letzten Klarsichtfolie und der letzten
Büroklammer Genüge getan ist zu sagen
genauso macht ihr das die Amerikaner die
amerikanische Ansatz ist so unendlich
viel pragmatischer und anders ist immer
mein Gefühl und da hat man auch keine
Sorge davor Industriepolitik wirklich zu
machen Zukunft wirklich zu gestalten man
geht nicht hin und sagt Verbrenner aus
ab dem und dem Datum sondern wir setzen
Anreize wir machen es so dass die Leute
das von sich ausmachen ist das denn
bessere Ansatz was passiert da gerade
ich meine in Deutschland
Industriepolitik ist etwas wirklich
gestalten ausrollen skalieren sehr viel
Geld in die Hand nehmen um richtig
reinzugehen in der neuen Technologie das
ist gehört nicht zu DNA der FDP das ist
auch okay das kann man alles vertreten
und ist sozusagen die der Glaube an die
Marktwirtschaft aber wenn man sich
anschaut Beispiel die Chinesen als
unsere Photovoltaikindustrie quasi
ausgeschaltet wurde haben die gesagt
okay das ist dieses Technologie der
Zukunft da gehen wir jetzt richtig
massiv rein das gleiche bei Windkraft
das gleiche bei E-Autos das gleiche bei
vielen Wärmepumpen ist das nächste Thema
vier Stück hintereinander die haben es
was haben die besser begriffen als wir
ich weiß nicht ob man die das in Flächen
redakt wirklich als
Symptom der Machtfülle und der
Möglichkeiten amerikanischen Politik
deuten sollte das wäre eine ziemliche
geschichtsklickung ehrlich gesagt ich
meine das Ding ist ja wenn wenn man sich
hier über das heizungsgesetz beschwert
dann sollte man sich den den Werdegang
ein bisschen Flächen reduction Arzt mal
ansehen ich meine das war über 12 Monate
die Leute haben im Kongress geheult das
Ding flog auseinander dann kam es wieder
zusammen und was dabei rausgekommen ist
wurde diktiert nicht von der FDP sondern
von West Virginia mit einer Bevölkerung
von 1,8 Millionen Menschen und
erlebenserwartung des niedriger liegt
als Nordkorea ich meine das ist der
eigentliche Hintergrund ich meine
deswegen
ist gewisser Weise dass das einzige was
durch das Nadelöhr der amerikan
deutschen Politik und zwar innerhalb der
Demokratischen Partei nicht über die
nicht über die gesamte Politik hinweg
hindurchgängen und auf Seite der Lobbys
war eben angesagt nur Karotten keine
keine Schläge also oder nur Zuckerbrot
und keine Peitsche ich meine das ist ja
das Grundprinzip das sind vielleicht
schon gedacht die machen es so weil die
Lobbys es so verlangen und nichts
anderes mitgetragen hätten eine Carbon
Bepreisung zum Beispiel
in Amerika vom Tisch wird auch sehr
große Streitpunkt werden zwischen Europa
und Amerika ich bin ich mein ich weiß
und es man könnte pragmatisch sagen man
sollte sich inspirieren lassen von dem
Fleisch mittagsschlagt und von seiner
Dynamik und seiner Größe ich habe gerade
die Chinesen angeführt die nicht gerade
da da würde ich ehrlich sagen dass man
das mit Vorsicht es ist es ist unter
anderem auch ein Ausdruck einer
bestimmten Krise das ist eine
Notmaßnahme dass er vielleicht hat sie
Chinesen sind natürlich ganz anders
geartet ich meine da ist es tatsächlich
fertig war sie haben Recht wir können
uns vielleicht im besten aussuchen
lieber nicht von oben zu diktieren was
die technologischen Antworten sind aber
welche chinesische Staat hat nicht
gezögert und sie bauen zwar viele
Kohlekraftwerke aber sie tun das als
Reservekapazität die werden jetzt kaum
angefahren nur in extrem Stoßzeiten
dienen sie überhaupt Produktion sie
werden die rechnen sich auch nicht die
Provinzen die das machen werden
ungeheuer Verluste einfahren was die
Chinesen in epischen Ausmaß tun wirklich
Welt ist durch ist Photovoltaik und
jetzt auch Wind und auch offshore und
zwar 130 Gigabyte in einem Jahr mehr als
Amerika insgesamt installiert hat und
das treibt alles an und dann erzeugt man
Skalen Erträge auch im elektrolytischen
Bereich z.B wo die Chinesen aufführen
bei H2 und das erzeugt eine Zwangslage
möchte man sagen aber eben auch
Möglichkeiten für alle anderen weil
diese billigen Produkte dann da sind und
weil wir Fahrt abhängig handeln müssen
und zwar unter enormen Zeitdruck muss
man gewisser Weise das mit einbeziehen
als Realität mit der man umzugehen hat
und das ist glaube ich die
Entscheidungssituation sich nicht
abgucken bei anderen aber sich
Bewusstsein was da passiert Stelle die
durch erzeugt werden was anderswo
anderswo gemacht wird und das ist aber
nochmal was bedeutet genau was bedeutet
das für uns also sie beklagen so habe
ich sie verstanden dass wir für für
Technologie für Forschung für all diese
Dinge auch um solche Dinge richtig
auszurollen richtig zu skalieren da
reicht kein Wumms und auch kein
Doppelpunkt da brauchen wir richtig Geld
sagen sie und zwar in einem Ausmaß wie
wir es in Deutschland eigentlich nicht
so richtig denken ich würde wir müssen
gerade in diesem Bereich glaube ich
anfangen fast utopisch zu denken ich
meine aber wenn Sie zum Beispiel sich in
China schauen Sie sich mal die Zahl der
Wissenschaft also naturwissenschaftliche
Unternehmen in Indien wissenschaftlichen
Doktoranden an das ist eine Explosion
der Zahlen und
Patenten international angemeldeten und
zwar nicht irgendein sondern viel
zitierten internationalen Patent in
China in China sehen Sie einen enormen
Anstieg in letzter Zeit letztes Jahr
23,6 Prozent plus ja in Patente
Anmeldungen wir Deutschland sechs
Prozent Minus genau das erzählt das sind
die Ausweise und wenn man sich dann den
Bundeshaushalt ansieht und sieht wie
dort die Gelder gestrichen werden für
Entführung beim BAföG wird gespart dann
muss man sich tatsächlich fragen was ist
die strategische Aussicht hier worum es
hier gehen muss um den Standort
Deutschland zu sichern ist ein gewisser
Weise hemmungsloser ausbaut das
human-kapitals das ist prinzipiell
vermutlich die einzige wirkliche Chance
nicht nur im Bett Bewerb sondern zu
bestehen sondern auch eine eine der der
zeitgemäßen Gesellschaft und und auch
Beschäftigungsstruktur zu erreichen das
kann ja nicht auf die Fortsetzung von
Verbrennermotor Produktion oder auch
seinen
abköniglingen das kann ja keine Zukunft
sein und diese Offenheit fehlt mir in
dieser Diskussion also da geht es auch
nicht um Nachahmung vor allem vor allem
habe ich nicht dass amerikanischen
Beispiel ist aber um einen neuen
europäischen Weg in diesem Sinne so
Dinge wie schwarz sind 0 Schuldenbremse
all diese Dinge was löst das in ihnen
aus wenn sie solche Wörter hören
wirklich ein
ein paar plexes Gefühl vor allem wenn
man meine ich begreife mich ja selbst er
hätte mag es vielleicht nicht glauben
als liberal kennen Sie ja nicht ein
Zuschauer und und genau und und
das ist der entscheidende Punkt ist was
denkt man als offen und was denkt man
als fix und wie ich die Position der FDP
verstehe ist die zukunftsoffenen Sinne
Technologie
Möglichkeiten Erträge die Geschichte Sie
sie über die Mobiltelefone erzählen ist
es bezeugen dafür wenn wir aber über
Finanzpolitik reden dann geht es um
fundamentale Weisheiten die die über die
Generation übertragen werden mit diesem
gender Image das schwäbischen Hausfrau
die das irgendwie immer verstanden hat
und so sollten wirtschaften und das ist
für mich ein Widerspruch ich will die
Finanzpolitik ähnlich offen denken wie
die Technologie technologische Politik
und und in diesem Sinne über die
Finanzpolitik diese Möglichkeiten öffnen
das heißt Schulden für mich ist Angst
vor Freiheit ist im Grunde Angst vor der
eigenen Entscheidungsfähigkeit man
unterstellt die Unfähigkeit von
Demokratien längerfristig und sinnvoll
zu wirtschaften man muss sich dagegen
der schützen indem man Regeln formuliert
die möglich sind Gewitter sind gewissen
Sinne wenig Sinn haben sollen sie sollen
also nicht wirklich wirtschaftlich
begründet sein sondern prinzipiell
feststellen man nimmt die Investitionen
zum Beispiel mit in die Schuldenbremse
hinein ausdrücklich weil man sich nicht
zumutet und zutraut laufende Ausgaben
von Investitionen zu trennen und das ist
ja das narrativ das konnte Deutschland
jahrzehntelang nicht also eine
flächendeckende Schuldenregelung die
alles weg dann merkt man dass das nicht
geht und dann hat man die Sonderform von
uns und mit den sonderfalls macht man
jetzt Politik bis das verfahrensgericht
irgendwann mal reinschreitet und man
kann sagen besser mit den sonderfalls
nicht aber sie sehen gewisser Weise in
welchen Zwiespalt man sich dadurch
hinein beginnen also man möchte gerne
glauben dass man die Schuldenbremse
einhalten
denn das ist ja auch ein Grundprinzip
einer liberalen Welt sich das Regeln
gelten sollen das sind ja
Orientierungspunkte für sie sozusagen
durch die Hintertür aber diese Regel
diese Fixierung
sich nicht mit der Realität
vereinbaren lässt und das ist ja
wirklich die Herausforderung für einen
modernen Liberalismus sich auch an der
Realität
Klimakrise polykrise die Herausforderung
der das Sicherheit in der Welt sich
keine keine keine schöne heile Welt dann
zu dichten sondern
entsprechend der durchaus dieser
Herausforderung auch auch zu regieren
das ist der Grund warum Gastbeitrag von
Ihnen gelesen muss sie sagten das ist
erkennbar dass Christian Lindner gerne
Finanzminister werden würde aber genau
das sollten wir ihm nicht geben ich
meine böse gemeint sondern zu seinem
eigenen Schutz oder wie habe man sollte
das ein personalisieren nicht ich es
geht ja nicht um Personen sondern es
geht darum was in einer solchen
dreier-koalition
es ist auf der anderen Seite eine riesen
Versuchung denn in diesem Job kann sich
ein konservativer liberale dann auch
gewisser Weise beweisen und dient dann
als Schutz gegen die radikalen Anmaßung
und die staatsexiertheit der Grünen und
der SPD das ist ja dann eine Position in
der man sich verlieren kann
aber die die gleiche Partei dann
gewisser Weise wie sie an deutschen
ständig zu bremsen ja das sind Gründe
nicht zu einer weltoffenen modernen
Liberalismus
gestalten nee das Gegenteil liberale
die Koalition der 70er Jahre denkt da
gibt es ja verschiedene Konstellationen
ich weiß Lamsdorf ist wieder im Gespräch
unter anderem und das ist das ist ja
eine
demonstriert gewisser Weise wie explosiv
diese Entscheidung sein kann und ja ich
meine er hat sich dann auf diese Rolle
kapuziert hat sie und nun sehen wer das
Ergebnis dass die gesamte Koalition
gewisser Weise eingefärbt wird durch das
Bedürfnis der FDP sich in dieser Rolle
Flagge zu zeigen also ich müsste jetzt
schon noch was sagen
etwas zu unpräzise nur weil der Christel
gerade eingeblendet war das ist
erfolgreicher Einbau einer Wärmepumpe in
Deutschland ich wollte nur sagen dass
Zeit die technologieoffenheit der fdpd
unabhängig davon ist mir ein bisschen zu
wenig zu präzise sie haben gerade vom
Inflation gesprochen das war so der
kleinste gemeinsame Nenner das ist
richtig wenn man sich die Dimension
anschaut weil ihre Empfehlung lautet ja
der Staat muss mehr Geld ausgeben
irgendwie mehr Geld investieren in neue
Technologien und dann werden die Dinge
besser das ist mir nicht präzise genug
denn
Location redakt ist tatsächlich gar
nicht so wahnsinnig groß etwa vom
Volumen ein Viertel dessen was die
Europäische Union
plant wir reden über 360 Milliarden
genau
das Vierfache ungefähr an
subventionsmechanismus hat die
Europäische Union also es mangelt nicht
an Subventionen in Europa das ist meine
erste Feststellung zweitens zum zum
Thema Haushalt der allein der Anteil für
Zinsen im Bundeshaushalt hat sich im
letzten Jahr verzehnfacht das heißt wir
geben zehnmal so viel Geld wie in der
Vergangenheit aus für gar nichts nichts
für Bildung nicht zur Militär nicht für
Zukunftsinvestition und ich will eine
dritte Zahlen zufügen die das Bild was
sie zeichnen glaube ich in ein anderes
Licht drücken die Wahrheit ist in fast
allen westlichen Ländern der Welt und
auch in Deutschland werden von 10 €
Investitionen 9 von der Privatwirtschaft
investiert
99% kommt von der Privatwirtschaft das
heißt er tut redet gerade über die 10%
die der Stadt machen kann und da bin ich
sehr skeptisch ob wir dafür
Schuldenbremse reißen in ein in eine
große Zinssituation laufen und am Ende
wieder als viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft
der Welt und größte Ökonomie in der
Eurozone vielleicht sogar die Eurozone
wieder in Schwierigkeiten bringen man
kann das schwäbische Hausfrau nennen
oder Haushalt tierische Tugenden ich bin
da sehr bei Christian Lindner ich halte
nichts davon zu sagen der Staat ist der
bessere Investor lasst uns mehr Schulden
machen in der Hoffnung dass sie gut
investiert werden ich sage lasst uns das
was die Amerikaner mich noch machen weil
vielleicht ist ja nur eine Seite wenn
ich mit Unternehmen spreche die sagen
Europa als Standort finde ich nicht mehr
so gut ich gehen die Vereinigten Staaten
dann sagen die mehr der Inflation
reduction Act als Subventionsprogramm
ist der Anlass das ist nicht der Grund
in den Vereinigten Staaten sind
Bürokratie auch in den Vereinigten
Staaten sind die Energiepreise geredet
wir müssen also aufpassen dass die
Energiepreise nicht durch die Decke
gehen und die Steuern geringer das heißt
zu sagen wir gehen bei den
Energiepreisen hoch indem wir was auch
immer an Technologien fest zuschreiben
alles wird teuerer oder wir machen mehr
Schulden und erhöhen die Steuern ist
genau das Gegenteil dessen was die
Amerikaner gerade machen also empfehle
ich uns doch bei den Steuern im
Zweifelsfall eher über Entlastung zu
reden und steuern Sie in Deutschland
sind die Steuern auch im EU-Vergleich
eher hoch gerade bei der Energiepolitik
über Entlastung zu reden und nicht über
mehr stark und mehr Ausgaben Frau
Künstler ja ich bin immer noch an dem
Anfang von dieser dieser wummsrede von
einem Tod also ja auch gesagt das ist
macht keinen Sinn zu sagen die
Amerikaner machen alles besser ich war
mal Korrespondentin von der ganzen Weile
und wenn ich jetzt noch hinfliege was
immer seltener passiert aber dann sind
viele von den Fenstern eben immer noch
nicht gedämmt in den USA also ich glaube
in Fragen der der Energieeffizienz und
so sind wir gar nicht so schlecht was
aber interessant ist an dem Punkt ist
dass wir natürlich in einer Situation
sind wo die Amerikaner mit Wumms jetzt
in bestimmte Technologien reingehen über
diesen Inflation redakt und die Chinesen
auf eine andere Art und Weise und dass
wir machen kann man eben dann unter
anderem an unserem Haushalt sehen der
ist ja so ein bisschen wie das das Buch
das Zeugnis was die Regierung ablegt was
zeigt wo sie hingehen will und wenn man
sich diesen Haushalt ang dann wird eben
gespart beispielsweise bei Mitteln für
die Digitalisierung dann wird gespart
beim Bafög also bei der Ausbildung von
Menschen jungen Menschen mit wenig Geld
dann wird gespart bei
Zukunftsinvestitionen also
beispielsweise die Bahn sagte
Verkehrsminister und sagt die Wahlen
bräuchte 40 Milliarden sie kriegt jetzt
deutlich weniger und das in dem Land wo
ich bin gestern gerade wieder Zug
gefahren wo das Bahn fahren wirklich
kein Spaß macht
33 Milliarden allein zu schwierige
Schulen also da machen
reinrufen schauen Sie sich mal anschauen
junge Menschen doch bitte einmal
Ausreden sie sich an wo überall gekürzt
sind für den Bildungsetat ihre
Ministerin massiv Bildungswissenschaft
und Bildung wird massiv gekürzt
wird machen wir den Faktencheck
hinterher aber das ist Bafög gekürzt
werden sie nicht bestreiten 400
Millionen sind da in in der Leute
das Verkehrsministerium im
Verkehrsministerium wird bei der Bahn
gespart und das ist glaube ich die
entscheidende Punkt ohne das will ich
die einzelnen e Kosten noch mal gehen
den Herr TuS macht wir sind im Moment in
der Situation wo wir anders als andere
Generationen vor uns sowohl für die alte
Generation sorgen müssen als auch für
die junge den müssen wir ein Land
übergeben was transformiert ist also was
umgehen kann mit einer Situation wo die
Klimakrise uns heftig hauen wird die
werden nämlich beispielsweise solche
Geschichten wie in der a hoffentlich
nicht aber möglicherweise häufiger
erleben und dafür viel Geld ausgeben das
heißt die früher wie denen helfen die
Wirtschaft Grün zu machen desto besser
und der Haushalt der jetzt bestellt wird
der der zeigt das nicht der ist nicht
eine Sprache von wir wollen wir gehen
jetzt rein und das Land mutig nach vorne
zu gehen
ja ich denke diese interkette
generationelle Frage ist wirklich
entscheidend und hier von dieser
dokträder abzukommen die sagt das was
wir unseren Kindern nicht hinterlassen
dürfen sind Schulden das ist ja wirklich
das ist zwar ein gewisser Weise
einleuchten aber geht doch am Punkt
vorbei es geht doch darum welche Anlagen
gewisser Weise welche Werte
wir für sie hinterlassen
wenn wir die zum Teil über Schulden
finanzieren ob diese Schulden denn denn
diese privaten Investitionen die sich
90%. die werden ja über Schulden
finanziert also der Spruch des Ministers
das durch Schuld nie langfristiges
Wachstum entstehen kann neulich in der
Fahrt ist ja wirtschaftliche fast
unfassbar wer hat denn Minister jemals
Staatsschulden hätten
nein soweit ich mich erinnere in diesem
Fall nicht das ist einfach die Schulden
es sind keine langfristigen wachsen
möglich und die die
jede Schuld ist jede Investition der
gewöhnlicherweise durch Schulden
finanziert das heißt die Frage für die
zukünftige Reaktion kann nur sein was
stellen wir Ihnen hin welche
Möglichkeiten bieten wir ihn ob es die
human-kapitalbildung geht und muss um
Infrastruktur
Ansätze zurück zur Klimapolitik das ist
das entscheidende und es fehlt einfach
längeren Zeit das heißt unsere
Generation muss es machen und zwar
möglichst schnell diese diese Tempo
Frage ist ist natürlich auch eine Frage
des Handwerks und wie man Gesetze
hinbekommt und alles andere aber Tempo
an sich ist genau der richtige Punkt
okay
natürlich um Staatsschulen das private
Investitionen auch privat Kredit
finanziert wenn es ja mehr als legitim
und erfolgreich aber wir sind die
Schulden des Staates und seit neun von
zehn je besser wir sind das Unternehmen
Lust haben in Deutschland zu investieren
desto eher erreichen wir die
Klimaschutzziele wenn wir schlecht
werden hohe Steuern haben erreichen wir
sie nicht weil die 10% die der Stadt
beeinflussen kann ist viel zu wenig als
Hebel der